good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 131 object class
safe special containment procedures no
special safety procedures are to be
taken with SCP 131a and SCP 131 be they
are free to travel about site 19 so long
as they do not attempt to enter any
restricted areas or attempt to leave the
facility casual contact with the
subjects is permitted but it is
recommended that such contact be kept to
a minimum to prevent the creatures from
forming an attachment to personnel
hourly tabs are to be kept on subjects
at all times failure to account for
their presence at these times
constitutes a level 1 lockdown situation
any report of abuse or mistreatment of
the subjects will result in a harsh
reprimand description SCP 131 a and a CP
131 be affectionately named the iPods by
personnel are a pair of teardrop shaped
creatures roughly 30 centimetres in
height with a single blue eye in the
middle of their bodies SCP 131a is a
burnt orange color while SCP 130 1b is a
mustard yellow at the base of each
creature is a wheel-like protrusion
which allows for locomotion suggesting
that the creatures may be biomechanical
in origin the subjects can move
surprisingly fast covering over 60
meters in a matter of seconds the
subjects however lack a braking system
which has led to some rather spectacular
if not overly amusing mishaps involving
the creatures the subjects have also
shown the ability to climb sheer
surfaces and have gone lost in the air
vents on more than one occasion the
subjects seem to have the intelligence
of common house cats and are insatiable
curious most of the time they simply
roll around the facility
observe
personnel at work and catching peeks of
other safe class scps
the subjects seem to be able to
communicate with each other via an
untranslatable high-pitched babbling the
subjects have never been observed to
blink even in laboratories when the
subjects have been videotaped for over
18 consecutive hours
the subjects seem to respond well to any
affection given to them and will quickly
bond to the giver of said affection much
in the same way a puppy bonds with a
human being they will follow anyone or
anything they've made a bond with
anywhere even into normally restricted
areas although curious the subjects
can't sense danger in their general
vicinity and if the object of their bond
begins to approach something they
register as dangerous for example Euclid
or Keter class objects they will swarm
around their bonded companions feet or
approximate extremities while babbling
in a panicked tone as if to warn them
because of the daily dangers faced by
site-19 staff in dealing with euclid and
cutter class objects it is recommended
that staff avoid making attempts to bond
with the subjects as it can pose a
distraction during delicate operations
and experiments and may pose a danger to
the subjects themselves see addendum 131
1 if the subjects are ignored by their
bonded target long enough they will
eventually lose interest in return to
their normal activities it should be
noted that the subjects require no real
care or maintenance from the site staff
they do not eat leave droppings or even
sleep it would seem that the only
sustenance they require is visual
stimulation although this requires
further study to verify subjects SCP
131a and SCP 131 B were found in a
cornfield outside in the year nineteen
they were promptly transported to site
19 viper hammer then downgraded to safe
class and given to free reign across the
site once it became clear they were not
broadcasting what they saw
to any hostile foreign powers addendum
one 31 one during an incident that took
place on the subjects followed one of
the cleaning staff on routine cleaning
of the container of scp-173 after their
normal attempts to warn the cleaner of
the danger were ignored the creatures
rushed into the container in front of
him and the other two personnel on duty
once inside the staff members observed
the subjects sitting in front of scp-173
and watching it intently as if aware it
could only move if unobserved the
cleaners ignored the presence of the
subjects and continued with the
bi-weekly cleaning as per standard
procedures when the cleaning crew left
the subjects did as well rolling
backwards slowly and never taking their
eyes off of scp-173 current applications
of scp-1000 and SCP 131 be has wardens
for scp-173 and perhaps other SCP which
require constant observation such as
scp-689 are being considered okay I
think that about does it for today thank
you all for listening and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell
dr. bright darius time Justin day o
philia gray der naam and je vous Jack
Corey Barker I run in and dr. Proctor
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you